welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
lady paulina
[Music]
and today's glorious purpose is bringing
you the best easter eggs hidden details
and things you missed in loki episode 4.
the new entry has a lot to talk about
and it explores sylvie's backstory
before taking things in a wild direction
we're going to be breaking it all down
in this video and make sure you stick
around until the end as we'll be giving
our spoiler-free review of black widow
now before we get into that i just want
to let you know i've recently done a big
breakdown for amazon prime video uk
discussing why i love invincible so much
it'll be linked in the description below
and huge thank you to everyone who
supported the channel
so i can get opportunities like this i
needed a hand
like bucky and you were there to give me
one and to me
your family well adopted family now
without the way
let's get into loki episode 4. okay so
this episode is called the nexus event
something that we've been told can
completely decimate reality if left
unchecked
several of these happen throughout the
episode and it's going to be absolutely
amazing to see what happens next
now we pick up with a young selfie in
her version of asgard
and can catch her playing with toys
amongst these are a dragon
which of course appeared at the start of
thor ragnarok and this is beaten by a
valkyrie who
also showed up in that movie
interestingly we can catch a giant wolf
toy next to a ship
and i believe that this might be fenris
now the tva arrive and escort her away
on the authority of the timekeepers
and it shows just how evil that the
organization really is
sylvie is just a child and the fact that
they're wiping her out for just
existing is worse than this channel now
she's taken through the procedures that
the older version of loki was
even down to popping up in the same
courtroom as we pointed out in our first
breakdown
this place contains an image of stan lee
amongst the timekeeper murals we learned
that sylvie stole the tampad from ravana
rensslayer as a child
when she was one of the minutemen and
since then she's been on the run
now ravano letting her go here very much
explains why selby lets her go at the
end of the episode
and again it's sort of like poetry they
right now go to the present
and we watch as ravano takes the golden
elevator to the timekeepers
who sit on their thrones as we know ren
slayer is one of the only people allowed
to speak with them
and it's very ominous seeing them
cloaked in darkness and smoke if this
was a disney show
which which it is yeah then no points
for guessing that these are the bad guys
now the central one is clearly seen as
the main figure
as he sits above the other two
throughout the series focus has always
been given to him
and it's no different in this episode he
looks a lot like what would happen if
jonathan mages was wearing makeup
and it could be hinting that this is
kang controlling at all now we cut to
the title screen
which we see fading in and in case you
missed our last video we went over how
this is actually an effect caused when
you photocopy something repeatedly
this is known as generation loss and
over time the quality diminishes
loki himself even referred to sylvia as
a photocopy last week
and it is quite interesting how she's
clearly the superior version now we then
jump back to the lobby
and see mobius asking rentslayer if he
can interrogate c20
but we learn that she's been killed
though we're told that this is because
her mind was scrambled and she started
to decline
we know that it's because she discovered
she had a life before the tva
c20 kept saying it's real after being
taken back to one of her memories
and thus she had to be murdered before
the truth was exposed
hashtag c20 didn't kill herself now our
next stop is lamentis 1
the purple planet that's also pulled
directly from the comics
we can see that the city the ark was
located at has been completely decimated
and on the outskirts of the town we get
the clip from the trailer in which
sylvie sits at a rock
interestingly they did change the cgi
slightly from the trailers
and they've now added in some spotlights
to explain why the characters are so
well lit
that's attention to detail guys now as
for sylvie aka the enchantress
no no not that one i still haven't
really discussed her comic book
backstory in a breakdown
so i thought i'd go over the 4-1-1 of
who the show version is also pulling
from
i know she takes elements of lady loki
too so if you want to run down of her
then definitely check out our full video
dedicated to her on the channel anyway
sylvie lushton to give her her full name
was born in oklahoma and she lived a
pretty normal childhood for the most
part
after ragnarok thor brought a version of
asgard to her home
and she woke up with morning glorious
purpose to discover that she now had
magical powers
desperate to do good she moved to new
york adopted an asgardian accent
and joined a group calling themselves
the young avengers though they weren't
the original and were just some crappy
knockoff of new rock stars that only got
popular because they did breakdowns five
minutes after a show release
sorry so talking about someone else
there now they were their own thing
but she did join the real young avengers
but was kicked out
and she ended up training at the
avengers academy however it was revealed
by lady loki that
she was the one who had given salvi her
powers and this was all an illusion to
trick immortal into thinking that they
were as guardian in order to cause chaos
you might know that the first
enchantress in the marvel universe was
actually called
amora and she was a close friend of loki
growing up
selvi caught her attention and the two
went head-to-head after the latter
realized that she had stolen her name
she was banished to one of the ten
realms but it was said that if she
survived
she'd be accepted by amora and that's
amore
now potentially we could be seeing what
our false memories planted into her by a
version of loki
in order to make her think that that's
her life the series itself has very much
been about false memories
erasing realities and also taking away
people's pasts and features
so potentially this theme could pop up
with sylvie and it would also explain
how loki is able to survive being pruned
at the end
maybe it's all an illusion we don't know
but we'll talk about that later on
now sylvie says she spent her life
running hiding at apocalypses
and she just wants to take down the tva
so she can be free
interestingly after bombing the timeline
we can see that it has been restabilized
so they must have cleared that up pretty
quickly as it hasn't really had much
effect on the show
however maybe they didn't fix things and
just left things as they were
which might explain why new york is
destroyed in the post-credits scene
now silvie says that what makes a loki a
loki is that they're destined to lose
but as loki correctly says they are
survivors
i mean this is a guy who has died
countless times and even though he
thought that his farewelling infinity
war would be his final one
he still came back swinging with a brand
new disney plus show
he even dies at the end of this episode
so yeah as he says
they are survivors now silvie holds
loki's hand as the ending of rogue one
plays out and this creates a nexus event
that alerts the tva
and they arrive and take them in loki is
told later in the episode that he will
be hashtag forever alone
and what happens here is they find love
with one another and this creates a
nexus event
as they're both variants they both try
to define what love meant to one another
last week
and the fact that they now somewhat gain
a shared love here
isn't meant to happen and thus it alerts
the tva i know mobius says it's sick and
twisted but
i don't see it really as anything
romantic and the showrunner did come out
earlier in the week and say that there
wouldn't be any romantic feelings
between them
they just realized that they're not
alone now shouts to christian from
beyond epic for pointing out that one of
the tva guards has a cover over their
eyes at this point
this is actually a subtle nod to the tva
chrono comes from the comics
which two had a similar optical device
placed over theirs too
loki tells mobius that the tva are lying
to him and thinks subconsciously he
knows this is the truth
which is why it kind of breaks him a bit
he has to laugh it off but you can tell
a plantsy idea in his head
and gets to him like people who say i
pronounce mischief wrong
i'll never forget i'll never forgive now
he's thrown into a memory prison and he
comes face to face with sif
who we haven't seen in the mcu for a
while i think her last appearance in the
timeline was in agents of shield but
marvel studios have been weirdly ashamed
of admitting that this show is connected
even though it went off and did its own
thing so thor the dark world may just be
considered the last time we saw her
she is however rumored to be in thor
love and thunder so it's nice that
they've got her popping back up here
interestingly in the comics loki
actually took over a body that was meant
for sif after the events of ragnarok
so it's a nice little easter egg that
they dropped her in here as a cameo the
tva repeat this bad memory over and over
which could be them using the time
twister which as we know creates a time
loop
interestingly the name of the time
twisters pulls from an alternate version
of the timekeepers
that turned evil in the comics loki
tries to talk sif around and we could do
a similar scene in which mobius tries to
talk ravona into letting him speak to
selfie
ravona says that nobody can speak to her
and she of course worries that others
might feel the same sympathy that she
did when she let her go as a child
we really see through these two examples
how time moves differently in the tba
as ravona hasn't aged today since sylvie
got away
whereas the latter has become a full
adult mobius drops a line about how he's
always watching over a loki
and potentially he's been through this
scenario several times before
or at least his variants have for some
reason he's had a soft spot for him
since the start
and there definitely could be more than
meets the eye here maybe loki went and
watched him on that jet ski before he
was taken in by the tva
and this would explain why he's felt so
sympathetic towards the character
as he may be the last thing he saw i
kind of feel like mobius was meant to
die in a jet ski crash but didn't
and thus this created a nexus point that
meant he had to be removed
from the timeline now mobius goes past
where sylvia is located
and we can see that she's been beating
up the minutemen as one has a bust-up
lip that they're padding with a bandage
mobius mentions that they fought the
cree an alien species in the mcu
titans which are not to thanos's race
and as we know his planet was destroyed
so potentially there was a timeline in
which survivors made it off
this would have created a nexus event
however it may also be thanos himself
as we know from avengers endgame that it
is possible to create other versions of
him
mobius also mentions vampires which is
likely helping to set a blade
which we know is coming down the line at
some point
now hunter b15 seems very curious over
what loki said
and this is because she too gained some
of her old memories
similar to c20 she was possessed and
when she woke up at rock's court she
almost had a look of realization on her
face
which we discover were elements from her
past in loki's memory
prison he admits why he cut sif's hair
and says that he does things for
attention
he's often lived in thor's shadow and
after realizing that he was a frost
giant
he likely felt betrayed and even more on
his own surrounded by the asgardians
this epiphany makes mobius arrive and
pick him up
and they return to the interrogation
room and loki talks about how they're
all in a loop of their own
which could hint towards our theory from
before this lip service paid to
cockroaches
which are of course known as being
survivors and this is very similar to
loki
who yes gets killed more times than
kenny now loki lies about working with
sylvie
in order to stay alive so that he isn't
sent back to prison
but he's devastated when mobius lies to
him about her being pruned
the tiny tier that forms in tom
hiddleston's eye is some next level
acting
and he pretends to be happy that she's
gone but mobius reveals that he's just
he's just pulling his leg now loki tells
mobius that everyone is a variant
but it's very much a boy who cried with
situation and mobius shrugs it off
however he himself has seen this play
out as he of course watched as loki
a variant that was brought in was
assigned to the ranks of the tva
this process has clearly happened with
others and deep down
he knows it's the truth hunter b15
rescues selfie and
in ravona's office she gets mobius to
sign the documents
he looks at the pen once more and it
could be that this pulls from his past
we have been theorizing that there's
another version of mobius running around
out there similar to comics
and this would explain the ring stains
in her office that ravana says are his
but that he doesn't remember putting
there ravana also says she didn't let
mobius see selvi because it's dangerous
but as we learn this is in fact a lie
using a sword trophy is a distraction
mobius swaps his tempad with hers and he
feigns exhaustion
b15 and selfie return to the rocks
caught disaster
and here the former lends the truth now
i love how b15 went from someone that
hated loki because he was a variant
to someone that learned they would want
to and that their prejudices were wrong
now we don't see what memory she gets
but it's clearly a happy one
like the time she clicked the thumbs up
button to help out an old friend
on a video now mobius replies c20s
debriefing footage
and this lines up with what loki told
him he returns to loki
and tells him that his shared love with
sylvie can bring everything down
upon escaping the prison mobius is
pruned and no it's a brutal moment
i do think that we will see him again at
some point in the series
he is of course a variant so there is
someone on the main timeline
probably riding a jet ski somewhere
right now and i hope we get a dark
knight rises esque ending
where logie returns to the main timeline
and just sees that he's happy
now till he has been returned but b15
has escaped
and she likely swapped her caller with
one that she could control
so that ren's slayer would be unable to
i kind of feel like she triggered things
at the same time as ravonna did to keep
up the illusion
and we do know that she had control of
their colours in the elevator
selvie asks red slayer if she remembers
what her nexus event was
but ravano says she can't recall it
though she does smoke beforehand
potentially showing that she's a liar
they're brought before the timekeepers
and i love how the design of their lair
looks very similar to penrose steps
which have appeared in the work of m.c
escher that that's not a rap name by the
way now they also showed up in inception
and these impossible staircases are of
course an odd to time loops
b15 shows up and frees them and loki
uses a sword to fight the security
which could be a nod to the sword of
sigurd from agent hamas god
loki and sylvie best everybody and she
reveals that they're actually machines
after beheading one in a very wizard of
oz-esque moment
now clearly something is behind this all
and potentially our theories about kang
being the one in control
could be right however there are others
it could be and it might actually be he
who remains
which is the creature that created the
timekeepers originally it could also be
doctor doom
as the machines are very similar to
doombots but i don't think they're going
to introduce such a big villain here
now i am leaning more towards the idea
that it's actually kang
as he is heavily linked in with the tva
and has already been cast
now the loki we've been following is
completely pruned
leaving just sylvie who asks to learn
everything
this is a huge gut punch that completely
changes the direction of things
but we get a post credit scene in which
we see that he's actually
alive he's a survivor he's not going to
get i'd stop with that now he
here he sees four versions of loki and
we see one
wielding magnet showing that there is a
variant that is worthy
the second is an alligator and this
could be a nod de throg
the frog version of thor there's also
kid loki who pulls from the comics
and this is someone that loki was
reincarnated as at one point
and lastly is oh loki wearing his comic
book accurate costume
now as for old loki he's sort of what
you want to call a loki classic
and he featured heavily in the book
agent of asgard that took place
right after one of the numerous deaths
of loki and he was reincarnated into a
younger body
after seeing how things always ended for
him loki wanted to divert from the dark
path that he had often gone on
and he became a force for good however
it was revealed that an old version of
loki was simply pulling the strings
and that he had gone through the motions
that the agent of asgard version had two
he divulged that upon completing his
tasks the all mother of asgard told him
that everything was a ruse
and that loki would always be viewed as
a villain a stepping stone so that
others could achieve greatness
this is something that has happened with
the show vision who of course
learned that he had helped to form the
avengers through his actions
thus oh loki decided to give asgard the
biggest villain they'd ever seen
and he fit the role perfectly getting
wickeder and wickeder
believing that he could be nothing more
he wanted the young version of loki to
follow in his footsteps
and we discovered that he'd been moving
through time manipulating events so that
it all fell into place
however much to his surprise his
intervention actually sent this variant
off on a new path
to do something different much in the
same way that the loki of old had been
used as a stepping stone to propel
others to greatness
o loki had been used to push the new one
into a brand new direction
now whether this aligns with what
happens at the end of the show or not we
don't know yet
but i do think it's important to bear
this arc in mind when discussing the
character
now i think here he is going to be
working with the character
but it would be hilarious if all they
did was backstab one another
they're also in a completely decimated
new york which we can see from the
avengers tower
this could be a timeline in which iron
man didn't direct the nico away from the
city
and it looks like because this is the
apocalypse that it's a safe place to
hide out
anyway absolutely incredible episode and
after last week's slightly lackluster
one
i'm well on board with this show again
this is easily the best in the series so
far
and if there was so many curveballs i
can't wait to see what happens next
now as for my thoughts on black widow
unfortunately
i'm probably gonna get some heat for
this but i was kind of disappointed by
the movie overall
up top i will say that it's not a bad
film per se but i just feel like there
were a lot of missed opportunities with
it
firstly i don't feel like this was a
good send-off for natasha
and beyond her childhood there wasn't
all that much that i learned about her
the piece to me very much felt like a
elena below the film
that just so happened to also have nat's
story running alongside it
and because of this it's difficult to
feel that she is a character
got the justice that she should have
there's also two very lackluster
villains in the movie in both taskmaster
and ray winstone strike off the ladder
is just sort of a stereotypical stalling
villain
whose plan you're not really sure of and
the former has been reduced to basically
being a killing machine
that doesn't have any true motivations
or conflict
there's a big twist with taskmaster that
changes things up from the comics
i think it might annoy some fans to the
level that the mandarin reveal did in
iron man 3.
they dropped the ball quite a lot with
the character and also the person
playing them
could have had a lot more to do as they
are a known actor
but they were brushed to the side now
minor minor spoilers here for the start
of the movie
so if you don't anything ruined about
the film then i highly recommend that
you turn off now
also please hit the thumbs up button if
you enjoyed the breakdown
and i'll see you on the next one now
after we get a flashback of natasha's
childhood
we see her sister elena working for the
red room which has complete control over
its soldiers
elena is snapped out of this by a
chemical and she goes
rogue now mind control elements rarely
work for me in fiction
and here it didn't really either
remember this is set just after natasha
has gone on the run
and she was someone who was under the
control of an organization
but decided to break free of her own
back rather than simply being magically
snapped out of it i really wish that nat
had been the inspiration for her sister
as that's more of a character choice to
me than what we get
the ending is also very strange as we
pretty much cut at a time where it looks
like something else is about to happen
before jumping to something else leaving
some questions over how we got from the
prior point to the present one
saying all that though the movie is very
very very good action wise
and it shows that the mcu can compete
with the likes of mission impossible
the combat scenes are really well
choreographed
as are the chase scenes and though
taskmaster doesn't really work as a
character
they provide a pretty good antagonist
for our group of heroes to stand up
against
david harbour and rachel wise are also
really good and the core casts provide a
certain feeling of family to the piece
that i think means the movie has at
least a heart to it
florence pew pew is also great too and
she's definitely going to be a big
character going forward in the mcu
she is the standout in the film for me
but that's not to take away from our
scarlet
who probably also has her best
performance in the marvel universe
as for the final post credits scene i
think that it sets up something quite
big
and it would have been interesting to
see if the original release
order of this coming before falcon and
the winter soldier would have worked
differently
personally i think it flows much better
being dropped in the order that it did
and though none of what i'm saying here
makes sense if you haven't seen it
you'll get it when it releases or when
you use the time stone to travel
forward now i feel like that scene is
one of the best parts of the movie
and i am hyped for what happens next so
overall it was a really
really strong action movie that i felt
was slightly let down perhaps because i
was expecting it to be this big send off
to natasha
and instead it was kind of a side story
that overall didn't add all that much to
her arc
and felt just like something used to
propel elena beloved into her place
there will be people that love this and
they're not wrong either just for me i
wanted some stronger villains and more
going on with this movie
overall it gets a 6.5 out of 10 and
probably ranks around the guardians 2
area in my opinion
obviously everyone is still gonna go see
it and i will be doing an ending explain
video as well as an easter egg one for
when the film releases worldwide next
week
so keep an eye on the channel also i
wanted to do a
black widow spider woman joke but i
couldn't think of how to wear it so
here's your half dose approach to it she
goes she goes splat
like a spider now you're welcome now i'd
of course love to hear your comments on
not only loki
what you think is gonna happen next time
and if there's anything we missed
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be ended into a prize store
on the 30th of july
in which we randomly pick three comments
so you can win an mcu boxer of your
choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode the winners of
june's competition are on screen right
now so that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the shangshi trailer which will be
linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you have any questions
over that movie
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been paul and
i'll see you next time
take care peace